joining us on the line is abigail fryer
she's a frequent Wall Street Journal
contributor author of the upcoming book
book irreversible damage the transgender
crazed seducing our daughters it is a
fantastic and vital book and a brave
book because you're not gonna get
anything but crap from people for
suggesting that maybe boys and girls
exist these days Abigail thanks so much
for joining the show thanks so much for
having me on so I'm sure that you
followed the Supreme Court decision on
LGBT rights now being read into the
Civil Rights Act of at 1964 the the
putting aside the sexual orientation
issue being read into the the Civil
Rights Act of 64 which clearly was not
meant to be the idea of reading
transgenderism that gender identity into
sex and the Civil Rights Act is utterly
bizarre it's really weird because it
actually puts title 7 which has now been
interpreted to mean that I can't fire
somebody for identifying as a member of
the opposite sex at my office it puts it
in direct conflict a title mine which
protects women in the workplace so what
do you make of the Supreme Court's
decision here so I sort of think of this
as an Amelia Bedelia opinion so okay so
course it pretends to be following the
text very much like you know the
character Amelia Bedelia doesn't in the
school in the children's books um you
know Amelia Bedelia they Izzy is the
housekeeper and she just follows
everything so literally and and that
mrs. Roger says prune the bushes so she
puts prunes in the bushes or dust the
curtain so she puts dust in the curtains
and she can never imagine what she's
done wrong and that's what Gorsuch you
know for the majority did with the title
7 of the Civil Rights Act he said that
look I'm just following this it's like
we can't discriminate on the basis of
sex and because a biological man who
shows up you know dressed as a woman for
work if you hire him that'd be partly
because of his sex then that must be in
violation of title 7 this is an
amazingly disingenuous claim the purpose
of title 7 was to ensure that women
wouldn't continue to be favored in the
broader society and course it's read it
in a way specifically to endanger them
so you know it really I don't think I've
ever read such a disingenuous opinion
it's pretty incredible one of my
favorite parts of the opinion is that it
overtly rejects the claim of trans Jen
people to be members of the sex to which
they claim membership but may make it
illegal for you to mention this in the
workplace so the the entire case for sex
discrimination on the basis of
transgenderism is you're treating a man
differently than you would treat a woman
right so that is acknowledging that a
man is not a woman right that is so if a
woman came dressed up in a dress one day
to work she wouldn't be fired but if a
man comes up dressed in a dress one day
to work then he and his fire than that
is discrimination because you're
discriminating against him as a man but
that is rejecting the claim of
transgender women that they are in fact
women right that is suggesting that they
are in fact biological men and you're
discriminating against them on the basis
that they are biological man so what
this is created is this bizarre
situation where if a man comes up it
comes dressed to work as a woman and
then I I'm not allowed to fire him
because he is a man dressed as a woman
and so we had to be discriminating on
the basis of him being a man but if I
say you're a man dressed as a woman so I
can't fire you then I have now committed
some act of sex discrimination in the
workplace that's right I mean he he
didn't you know it's that's right he
sort of acknowledges transgenderism and
and you you expect you know by his own
logic do you expect him to reach the
opposite result that he does I mean he
you know he sort of gave title seven a
sex change operation you know in his
pretending you know to have a literal
you know or is pretending to have a
textualist reading he says you can't
discriminate against someone you know
wherever you treat them differently by
taking note of their biological sex and
this is for the reasons you said it's
going to have profound implication he
denies you know the majority under
course it's writing for the majority
denies that it will have impact on
women's only spaces in terms of locker
rooms bathrooms battered women's
shelters prisons but but of course by
the own logic of the opinion those
things go out the window there's no
following the logic of this precedent
there really is no way to have to bar
biological men once again on the basis
of their sex as you said on the basis of
their being man from entering a woman's
locker room this is a very bad opinion
for women I mean Avigail what do you
think do you think that I feel like this
is the cultural precursor to the notion
that it is a form of child abuse to ban
people from things like transgender
surgery because this
obviously part of a broader movement to
suggest that there is a if you are
transgender then all of your claims are
not only are not oh you not only have a
right to make the claim which obviously
you do but you are you are legitimate in
that claim as a matter of law which
would suggest that if you're a 17 year
old or a 16 year old your parent denies
you a transgender surgery theoretically
they're being abusive it feels like this
is part of a line that is leading to
that conclusion it's really interesting
I think I think that's right I hadn't
thought of that but I think that's right
because they acknowledge transgender
status as if it's this immutable thing
that you're just come with so if you
have you know you know it's sort of you
know and like any other status you know
there are women and then there are
people with transgender status and of
course you can't deny women their rights
so you can't deny anybody who's trained
has transgender status their rights and
that right could include the right to no
surgery or all kinds of other things I
mean you know that one of the things
that you know Alito and others raised
which i think is really important is all
the litany of constitutional rights that
are now you know coming right in front
of the steamroller and and one of them
of course is I don't know how a
religious school can fire a teacher who
decides to start cross-dressing in the
classroom you know there's a ministerial
exception but I don't know that they'll
grant that for a math teacher in the
classroom it's it's gonna have profound
implication it and not just in schools I
mean I've been worried about this too
because you know I think both of us went
to Jewish schools and there was the the
there's the Hebrew side and then there
was the secular side the secular side
there were just you know normal secular
teachers trying to trying to claim they
have to abide by
you know Jewish standards obviously is
not going to hold it's gonna be very
difficult to say that you can see that
you can see the court saying well if
you're a rabbi you're not allowed to
crossdress but if you're the science
teacher then you're totally allowed to
crossdress at this school that
completely disagrees with with this
particular set of values it also has
significant ramifications for health
care because obviously there's a lot of
Catholic hospitals and Catholic
hospitals might say you know what we
don't want to perform a transgender
surgery well now you are denying
somebody their rights perhaps under the
Civil Rights Act of 64 through this
rereading I think that's exactly right
and I actually expect that's where the
court would go
I mean just just following this
precedent and we never know but just
following this precedent that that is
what I think they're setting up because
you know their claim would be you know
well it's yeah as you said I went to a
Jewish school and that well it's just
the math teacher that doesn't affect
your values and alito notes this into
his dissent he says if you're a
religious institution in which you do
not you know believe that boys should be
dressing as girls you know biological
voice shweet it's really hard to convey
that message when you then hire all
these teachers even if it's on the
secular side who are you know in
violation of your values so I think
you're right that's what this is teeing
up Abigail Shriver she's a frequent Wall
Street Journal contributor author of the
upcoming book book irreversible damage
the transgender craze seducing our
daughters so Abigail I'm sure you've
also been following the controversy
surrounding JK Rowling over in the UK
who committed the unpardonable sin of
mentioning that it is threatening to
women if you say that a man is a woman
and that subjecting women to you know
having to share locker rooms with
biological men is in fact not good for
women what did you make of the
controversy and do you think that there
will in fact be a cultural backlash to
this because it seems like the
transgender movement is moving so
quickly on so many fronts that it's even
placing people like JK Rowling
off-limits I you know I hope there is a
backlash to this because this is getting
ridiculous I mean she she yeah you know
it was amazing I just so happens that
she mentioned exactly what my book is
about which is you know she pushes she
points out that if she if she had been a
teenager teenage girl going through all
the things that teenage girls go through
and knew that being becoming a boy could
have been an option she would have
considered it and it's something that
all women go through we go through this
period of adolescence in which life is
really confusing and your body is
changing and things are hard and right
now you know teenagers are presented
with the option you know will then
change your gender have some
testosterone and that's that I hope
there's backlash to that because right
now what we're seeing it spread through
the schools so quickly in numbers that
don't make any sense with gender
dysphoria and I think JK Rowling was
right on the mark and I you know I I
hope there's a backlash to the amazing
attempts to can
fill her for just speaking the truth so
maybe you can talk for just a minute
about some of the threats that that this
does present particularly to young and
vulnerable girls I mean JK Rowling makes
the claim and this has been backed by
other claims in the UK that a
disproportionate number of autistic kids
are now basically suggesting they're
transgender there has been significant
shifts in the gender of the people who
are claiming that they are transgender
that it used to be very much biological
males claiming their friends gender now
it seems to be a majority of females in
the UK that the numbers have really
spiked what's happening here it is it's
a majority and actually all across the
West women have taken over the
demographic young teenage girls have
taken over the demographic and that's
what my books about out of nowhere
teenage girls with no history of gender
dysphoria are now the leading
demographic and what you know what's
happening here
you know as I say in the book is pure
contagion and this is based on you know
the research of public health researcher
Lisa Lippmann this is not my own
scientific work but I'm just the
journalist who with the story and they
have out of nowhere taking this on it's
a pure contagion meaning it's the thing
they've cast they've sort of reached out
for to claim to sort of as a location of
their distress this is what they call it
gender dysphoria but they might call it
you know it's demonic possession and
they might call it anorexia or being too
fat I mean they could have called it
anything that you know peer contagion
you know or or that you know these
hysteria go by and and you know the this
is what's happening it's happening all
across the web Abigail's fryer her brand
new book which is out shortly is called
irreversible damage the transgender
crazy seducing our daughters go
pre-order it right now abigail is one of
the bravest members of the media for
actually talking about an unmentionable
unpardonable topic now you'll really
appreciate the time thank you so much
great to be on
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content